today I'll show of the Planet of the
Apes we're gonna watch the trailer yeah
that's it nothing that big we're gonna
watch the trailer for war of the plan of
the apes today on fat man I'm back man
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to fat man I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark Barnard
and guess what we're gonna do kids the
laziest thing you could do on the
Internet
watch it they're gonna watch us watch it
we're gonna watch the trailer for War of
the Planet of the Apes
I have not seen this trailer of you I
saw it yes you cheating bridge master
bra you know I've not seen it so you
gonna you gonna drunk on and cook yeah
uh here but I'm gonna put this out there
I'm an old-school og Apes fan all right
I love those movies and I understand a
lot of people think these movies look
better but that's just like when you
show me a CGI shark I'm like that don't
look like a shark cuz jaws looks like a
shark to me because that's how I was
raised on jaws I get my special effect
that giant puppet is a shark it is if a
shark doesn't look like jaws and Lego
looks fake to me same thing with these
new plan of the Apes movies I understand
that you know all the CG geniusness that
goes into making it but come on man you
don't need that that's a lot of money
just put the rubber masks on now which
of the og Apes is your favorite Oh James
the first one what a real question what
a great question mark um I'm gonna I got
to bring up my boys go there's somebody
[ __ ] about me on the internet though
you're talking too low it's when I get
wistful know what I'm like a Dewey I
love old me um the okay which is my
favorite Apes movie
I love playing the Apes mmm a love
beneath the Planet of the Apes
really yeah Oh God maybe they I'm not
look you know me I'm not very selective
critical all the apes move up until the
last one battle for less good can't
remember that much but yeah not as good
as the other
okay so plan of the Apes yes genius
perfect beneath the Planet of the Apes
I'll still go with pretty [ __ ] great
for me especially cuz like [ __ ] fight
and I reveal my innermost self to my
bomb and they worship the [ __ ] [ __ ]
soul and you got very hippy for me
though
got very like that's mine to mine attles
yeah he looked at transcendental LSD for
my apes had the guy who played King Tut
in it I'm good enough for you Batman
show okay so that's beneath maybe my
favorite of all time Apes movie oh it's
a toss-up it's a tie between escape from
the plan of the Apes nice that was where
they took it and refreshed it by
bringing it to the present deck
cornelius and zira
and later on baby Milo and Ricardo
montalbán yes who helps their young baby
escape who becomes Caesar in conquest
conquest so it's for me [ __ ] it's tough
dude I love you have no idea how much I
love these Apes movies that's why it's
like you know tough for me with the new
Apes movies because I'm like yeah but
where's Roddy McDowall you know and
don't get me wrong like not every Apes
movie will do cuz there was that one Tim
Burton one word you know no we don't
talk about that ya never to be spoken of
again the cartoons I watched all the
cartoons and I was a kid I had some of
the Mego dolls like eight before Star
Wars like Apes was my franchise and when
430 movie would do Apes week and show
every [ __ ] movie in a row oh that was
my I was the prime time in my life
everything else has been downhill
honestly mark the first time I ever came
to LA I think I was 12 or 13 years old
and I just remember driving through
Century City and saying ah this is
conquest of the Planet of the Apes this
is where the [ __ ] go crazy the plan of
the yay absolutely right it's still
today looks like it if you know what to
look for in Century City they got these
big buildings we're like ABC used to be
before you know Disney bottom and [ __ ]
and before the dying art tower yeah I'm
not going on so me we're just like right
around the block it's awesome sometimes
if you're a movie buff living in LA
oh it's always like and that's how you
get an accident but uh but the yeah you
see century's City Plaza looks like
where court where Caesar leads the
[ __ ] rebellion with all the flames
and he's like no you know no she says no
yeah I forget I love it so much I forget
and Century City is also where half of
is I think yeah I think you're right
about that yeah Kanaka and the other
time movie that he made with andrew
niccol like that that's his jam like
it's version the future is Century City
for most of us who grew up watching
playing the apes it is remember where
like pick your name and you know he goes
opens the book Caesar a leader you know
so I love those movies but remember
there was I heard there's a different
ending
you're like for conquest of the Planet
of the Apes the ending was like you know
and tonight you know let this be the
beginning of the Planet of the Apes and
it ended in this is it out of rebellion
shit's gonna [ __ ] go haywire but at
the time they released that movie I
think it was around the time of like the
Newark riots enough and there was like
huge racial divides in the country so
they were like let's not mirror that and
they toned it down so when you watch
conquest he builds this [ __ ] hate
filled speech where you're like kill
kill all the [ __ ] humans do it Caesar
and then all of a sudden he goes and
they'll cut into him it's not on his
mouth but they cut into his eyes and
he's like but not today you know almost
like you know poochy I have to go away
to my home boy at least I'd like to buy
the world a coke and teach them all the
same it wouldn't reshoot they were like
just going closing his eyes we'll loop
the line and be like but don't kill
people today Jim maybe not so much to
call to Armageddon but it doesn't matter
that movie is [ __ ] dynamite like oh
ah escape from Planet of the Apes
conquest supplying the Apes you can
watch back-to-back and then loop back
and watch plan of the Apes yes who you
know who wrote plan of the Apes Pierre
Boulle a the novel Rod Serling wrote the
screenplay great rod the green Rod
Serling who like was as always in the
twilight zone was always telling a story
about society through science fiction
same thing yet here in many ways maybe
the greatest writer to ever work on a
screen yeah is my money
gave him a single my money because
here's the thing he runs early Rod
Serling over the nine years I think
Twilight Zone ran he wrote half of those
episodes and that was like 40 episode
seasons so he wrote something like they
were like half hours
half-hour episodes no recurring
characters except for him so everyone is
brand-new everyone is new characters
everyone is a new world that is the
biggest feat of heavy lifting I've ever
seen on television
excellent point in did it for ya he did
it for answer he wrote something like
300 episodes of that show and there are
not a lot of bad ones and even the bad
ones are interesting yeah there's no
such thing as like there's terrible dry
light zone it's just like yeah yeah like
you hear of like it all make you go huh
no but like you hear of these like you
know Aaron Sorkin wrote every episode of
The West Wing he wrote over episode of
sports night J michael Straczynski wrote
every episode of bet of Babylon 5 didn't
really he did except for one than Neil
Gaiman wrote no good for you um JM s
like a [ __ ] yeah but I still
think that that for sheer heavy lifting
and sterling and single it annoys
quality ratio Twilight Zone still wins
if you don't know nobody knows he's a
[ __ ] writer you're looking at a
writer that's a ride out I'm just saying
he's a wicked writer
wicked broad up okay so now did you see
plant of the Apes rise we got to finish
one more oh sorry
battle for the Planet of the Apes in the
original series mmm intimates yeah I
mean there's some scenes of fighting and
[ __ ] like that but like some of your
favorite characters are missing and
stuff and Caesar's kid dies remember
Milo you know what's-his-name Milo is
that what they named in what it was Milo
it might have been cuz Milo was
originally Caesars name like they named
their baby cornelius and zira named the
baby Milo no doesn't core then remember
that other user gets killed and they're
like that's big model and that's Milo
goes to mmm Ricardo Montalban and later
on he chooses his name is Caesar
so then Caesar has a kid and that kid
might be named Milo that were taupe or
Taylor maybe names a kid Taylor does he
do that better I don't think it's a
let's pretend it does but he the kid is
like you know being [ __ ] he's over here
and I think the gorillas talk about like
we got a
or and they see him and they go to chase
him and he [ __ ] falls out of the tree
and dies and so it sets up a war with
like you know the Apes like Cornelius
wants to be friends with the humans and
the gorillas are like they are like good
human as our dad helmet I love those
movies that being said that's the past
let's concentrate on the future yes what
was your question
uh did you see the two movies that
precede war for clamps I did raaah Donna
the planets and rise of the planet I did
vice versa
I know it's sacrilegious to say this but
I think I like Dawn more no okay I
Nessie love reaction all right no I did
I liked dawn more than the second one I
thought the second one was fine but I
like I remember when it came out people
like [ __ ] Jane yes and you know I saw I
was I guess all right but I like the
first one more telling the story and how
it ended I like the post-credits
sequence where you saw the law
jurisprudence and like that's what
happened
but anyway so now this so I like the
second one just mine this one those got
a good planet war for the planet war for
the plan of these [ __ ] yes those of war
for the Planet of the Apes as a metal
title what is it good for yeah
absolutely everything oh my god so we're
gonna wash the [ __ ] out of this right
now
and I'm watching clean this is fresh
branch reaction here we go man we're
gonna wash the [ __ ] out of the trailer
for war for the planet yeah so we got
the green screen now green screen up and
we're pressing and we're watching that
Oh where's the beaches yeah put a
[ __ ] Statue of Liberty huh mmm all
right that's pretty dope I mean giant
chimpanzee on a what lady holding on to
oh I like that guy in the light in the
other movie yeah he's awesome tell him
what is this cat's name yeah Andy Serkis
know the character now that's Caesar is
Caesar dick
all right
yes gunfire good man verse eight
I like the fortresses man needs me one
close dude I'm sorry
like in the old movies that the leather
[ __ ] like that
yeah just taking out humans with guns
that Woody Harrelson
it looks like woody house that is what
yeah [ __ ] you little fuzzy mess yeah
shaving his head woody woody house and
playing a man go if it looks like you
know Eamon Kurtz
doh [ __ ] yes I like the I like the
orangutan new character yes [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] no don't do that don't hurt him
oh [ __ ] I don't like that Wow holy [ __ ]
you this award
[Applause]
[ __ ] you take all my money god dammit
that looks good
not strong I know what I'm gonna so sure
they don't even need to put a PS to that
let's watch that again real quick that's
kind of dope man you know we'll just
Jimmy a [ __ ] watch women begin I mean
chimpanzees on horseback carrying guns
that looks like what battle for the
Planet of the Apes tried to look like in
the last of the series but they had like
no money [ __ ] left and sure those
were those are the years of diminishing
returns yeah see starting on the beach
reminds me of the ending of the Vienna
planetís they're going in a different
direction
that's dope man giant chimpanzee with a
[ __ ] shotgun on his back riding a
horse I'm gonna say it again I like this
orangutan he was a good character I
remembers me he was like the keeper of
the journals I mean why do they don't I
don't know why they don't call him dr.
Zaius that is [ __ ] what they might as
well he offered them peace mankind
always [ __ ] it up yeah of course he did
I remember that part of the movie Bay at
the dam they had to get going and she
also he built his fortress behind it
ties into the last notice mark again
that is it's pretty dope this I like
what the [ __ ] that's great he is fully
channelling Mackey McConaughey from
whistling rain of fire oh my god the
bald with a beer yeah heavy chefs a
little soiree mention a semi keeps his
[ __ ] shared dough shoot him shoot in
the back
yes [ __ ]
here's a pig come on that's [ __ ] dope
like this giant ape suppose now house I
don't like that I love that push like
yeah [ __ ] shoot me you were ever gonna
shoot that [ __ ] care he's the money
don't kill season that's dope man
guerrillas arming up [ __ ] Anna it's
amazing
crush your skull the bang so that's a
dude it looks like you a mercy before
next time I saw him is I luck you I'm in
that looks way [ __ ] cooler than the
last movie I know a lot of people like
to last mmm but again I'm gonna say it I
like the first movie of Franconia those
dopes but that yeah that looks [ __ ]
phenomenal I mean and I like looks like
they took that last I won't interrupt a
movie finished looks like they took the
last few minutes of that last plan a
movie where they were warring and then
did all [ __ ] movie about it yeah get
away I just love the fact we talked
about a bit with Westworld that it's
that's that series started you feeling
like you were sympathizing with the
human characters cuz you're human and
you're walking in and you're like aw
we're gonna have fun in this fucked-up
place but as time goes on you become on
the side of the host you are you're
absolutely rooting for them to uh prowl
that's true in these three movies like
we are now voting almost with our money
to see the apes destroy humanity we want
there to be a planet eh they keep
selling us a planet it's really we keep
giving you money come on is that so at
the end of the theme read for the
credits like with all these humans dead
it is finally a planet of the it's over
or debate over the Planet of the Apes
are they and are they meaning to tie
into no no I mean that first one sort of
dovetails in like to talk about the
Icarus mission they talk about you see
the things start to be that's why I
liked it so much cuz I'm like ah it ties
into my book in the end eh movies I mean
I think it's also posted basically
nestled between like the first and the
second between long marky-mark I'm good
um yeah listen why I'm [ __ ] look
let's you know it's bad this we only
talk about Apes past unless it's the
oldest Pascucci games rules
this looks [ __ ] dope this looks like
the movie that battle of the plant
battle for the Planet of the Apes wanted
to be way back in the day with no money
war for the Planet of the Apes the
[ __ ] giving you a war that looks
pretty dope it looks dope man
and the circus bringing it is he whose
director Matt Reeves she also do the
second the second one yeah and I think
also if I remember correctly did the
first Cloverfield movie oh I like that
movie yeah maybe also do the Paul Bearer
way back in the day I don't think so but
I could be wrong somebody may be right
I may be crazy oh but it just may be
lunatic that would ease play and what he
Harrelson man has got a career that
won't [ __ ] quit nope I mean you know
I was clicking through cable the other
day and I saw Wildcats and that was like
shut up member knipes he was early I was
early woody that might be the first
woody anybody ever had Wow morning woody
if you will yes why a wild cat it sort
of kings finer than diamond rings that's
why we're here to sing Goldie Hawn Wow
vodka football over Wildcats football
she's in a new movie
uh yes snatched with with Amy Schumer
wait what [ __ ] Oh
snatch was well snatch was Brad pinching
and Guy Ritchie so this is snatched Edie
yes were they cutting it close doesn't
look good you see that uh trail looks
fun if your name is Schumer fan there
you go yeah and who is no jobs though
right now if they played mother daughter
get kidnapped in like Thailand or
something I mean it's a genre but it's
not like right it's a woman yeah so
somebody say online they were like and
be with the we you know we reviewed road
one a lot of people have watched it but
they were going like why why the [ __ ]
the show's called fat man I'm Batman why
are they talking about Star Wars if it's
not clear like that title is just
something that we kind of talk about
everything it's no an umbrella yeah
thank you
yeah sheltering us from the office [ __ ]
that is not geek news yeah but there'll
be more Batman coming yeah you know what
I started doing well I'm playing the
Batman telltale games thing telltale is
a company that did these amazing
Walking Dead games which are basically
almost like choose your adventures like
a mostly text-based
but they just did one for Batman so
you're like putting Batman through his
paces and Catwoman shows up a commission
to go
it's pretty cool so far what's it called
where do you go
it's Batman I came out of the [ __ ]
rest of the name of it but it's by
Telltale Games by Telltale Games yeah
where do you play it on my ps4 I go oh
it's a good yes all you think there you
go yeah so so we'll talk about that on a
later date there's a hot tip right
making my way through it all right but
yeah but is fat man bad man we talk
about a lot of [ __ ] yeah used to him if
you haven't figured that out now
yeah if you're just coming here
expecting as you know them a Batman and
don't act like you never saw the show
before come on come on
we know yeah all about it it's not that
popular but but we've seen our numbers
we know you know there it is that's all
we got for you this week man war for the
Planet of the Apes [ __ ] thumbs up yes
looking good
Cantabrigian July yeah I'm in for this
one way more than the last one it seems
like uh there it is [ __ ] for fat man
I'm Batman I'm Kevin I'm mark barnard
come back next episode same fat time
same fat chance podcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you